économique de la région auxquels nous
sommes tous ici très attaché merci la
parole est un monsieur sylvain berrios
monsieur le président la question porte
sur les conséquences désastreuses la
fermeture brutale et sans constatations
des voies sur berge à paris
les objectifs étaient clairs
initialement réduire la pollution aux
particules fines réduire le trafic
automobile et rembourse et permettre de
retourner les voies sur berge au pas au
parisien les résultats sont
catastrophiques
aucun impact positif sur la pollution
selon airparif une augmentation massive
des bouchons je rappelle que c'est + 25
% de trafic supplémentaire sur cintres
et tronçon du périphérique + 30 % et 340
km de bouchons sur l'a4 l'a86 ces 48 %
supplémentaires qu'elle ouvre 84 %
supplémentaire qu'est l'hôtel de ville
91% quai henri iv et rer a complètement
saturé c'est également près de 6000
jours de travail détruit pour les petits
entrepreneurs
et puis enfin ces deux sont des quais de
berges déserté par les parisiens eux
mêmes pourtant c'est sur la foi de ses
résultats calamiteux désastreux que le
maire de paris a décidé de la fermeture
de l'axé ouest est c'est à dire la rue
de rivoli
c'est un bras d'honneur fait aux
franciliens au commissaire enquêteur aux
entrepreneurs aux 130 maire de métropole
du grand paris mais également
gouvernement qui s'était engagé devant
l'assemblée nationale à respecter la
plus large concertation avec les élus
avant toute autre décision définitive de
la ville de paris ces destructions
massives en matière d'économie
d'écologie d'emploi sont catastrophiques
pour la région ile-de-france et la
métropole du grand paris monsieur le
premier ministre agit d'une question de
santé publique
une question économique une question
essentiel pour la vie des franciliens
allez-vous mettre un terme hier la
transition à monsieur alain vidalies
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
de la mer et de la pêche
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le député après l'épisode que la france
et paris particulièrement 1 vient de
connaître notamment s'agissant de la
pollution atmosphérique
je dois reconnaître l'opportunité de
votre question parce que c'est une
question de santé publique c'était les
mots importants dans votre dans votre
question des milliers de morts des
dizaines de milliers de gens qui ont des
maladies chroniques dont l'origine est
connu c'est pas un problème parisien
c'est le problème de l'ensemble des
agglomérats des grandes agglomérations
et je dois dire l'air y compris en
france où cette question est traitée par
exemple à lyon mais aussi à bordeaux par
des élus avec me semble-t-il les mêmes
réponses
les mêmes réponses qui sont des réponses
en matière de transport collectif en
matière de diminution de la présence
dans la voiture est ce que nous avons le
choix parce que c'est ça la vraie
question qu'est ce que vous proposez
l'inertie renvoyait le problème à demain
mais les maladies n'attendent pas la
pollution n'attend pas cette question
elle est devant nous il faut des mesures
et deuxièmement il ya une question
démocratique
évidemment la municipalité de paris le
maire de paris s'est présenté aux
élections et a été élu avec ce programme
là c'est propre rocher un élu
d'appliquer le programme qui a été
validé je ne pense pas que ce soit
acceptable dans cet hémicycle et dans
tous les cas je veux le dire
le gouvernement souhaite vérifier avec
le préfet de police dans un cadre très
large les conséquences des décisions qui
ont été prises mais dans tous les cas je
veux le répéter la position du
gouvernement contrairement à ce que vous
soutenir
c'est que dans cette affaire compte tenu
la gravité des enjeux l'inertie nez